supongamos que tengo una transformación
que va de r2 en r2 y como siempre esta
transformación lo voy a expresar como el
producto de una matriz por un vector
todas las transformaciones lineales se
pueden expresar de este modo aunque
realmente no hemos probado esa 1 así que
te de equis va a ser igual a la matriz
1236 multiplicada por el vector x que
puedo representar como x 1 x 2 bien esa
es mi transformación y lo que hace es si
aquí tengo mi dominio tengo mi dominio
que es r 2 en sí podría dibujar esto
como transformándose en sí mismo pero
creo que sería más claro si también
dibujo por acá otra copia de r docs
bien entonces la transformación te lo
único que hace es simplemente me asocia
a un elemento de r2 me asocia otro
elemento en r2 no necesariamente
distinto bien entonces supongamos que me
fijo en el conjunto en el subconjunto
sdr 2 supongamos que me fijan en su
conjunto ese que está formado por el
vector 0 en el re 2 el vector 0 0 y el
vector 12 también en r2 ok esto es un
subconjunto de r2 que lo puedo pensar
como único dominio así que déjenme los
pongo aquí supongamos que este puntito
de aquí representa el vector 0 0 y aguas
no estoy graficando realmente no esto no
es una gráfica simplemente es una
ilustración así que voy a decir que este
es el 0 0 y voy a suponer que este es el
vector 1 2
y ahora me pregunto quiénes son todos
los vectores de r2 que se transforman en
estos elementos quiénes son los vectores
que al aplicarles la transformación
llego a elementos de s
en el vídeo pasado definimos eso como la
prima gen de s habíamos denotado esto
como de al menos 1 de s
y esto lo que era es la prima gen
pre imagen
d
ese respecto
respecto
y es importante decir respecto a qué
transformaciones estamos tomando la pre
imagen porque de otro modo no tengo no
tengo forma de saber quién es el que
está enviando los vectores así que bien
definimos eso y dijimos que como
conjunto esto era lo mismo que las x en
r2 en mi dominio de dominios r2 tales
que al aplicarles la transformación de
tve keys pertenece a s
es decir a este conjunto aquí si él
transformó el vector x quiero que me dé
el vector 0 o el vector 12 así que esto
en realidad
esto en realidad no podría escribir así
los x en r2 tales que al aplicarles la
transformación llego a miembros de ese
pero quién es la transformación es
multiplicar por esta matriz vamos a
llamar esta matriz la matriz a entonces
este conjunto es el mismo que los x en
r2 tales que a por x
es igual a el vector 0 0
a por x es igual
el vector 12
y eso eso es precisamente la pre imagen
la pre imagen de el conjunto s y para
encontrarla tengo que resolver este par
de ecuaciones
bien y que me dice esta primera
actuación que me hice esa ecuación de
ahí pues la matriz a es la matriz 1 2 3
6 y la voy a multiplicar por un vector x
1 x 2 y eso me tiene que dar el vector
000 y quizás ustedes en cuenta quizás
reconozcan esto como el espacio nulo de
la matriz a de la matriz 1236 así que
eso es el espacio nulo y también además
de esa ecuación tengo que resolver esta
ecuación porque quiero llegar a ese sí
que me puede dar 0 o me puede dar el
vector 12 la segunda ecuación sería la
matriz de nuevo 1 236 multiplicada por
el vector x 1 x 2
y eso me tiene que dar el vector 12
perfecto y vamos a resolver esto el modo
más fácil es usar una matriz aumentada
cómo le hacemos siempre así que quién
sería mi matriz aumentada mientras
aumentada sería la matriz 1 2 3 6
aumentada con esta columna 0 0
y en este caso acá quien sería mi matriz
aumentada pues de nuevo sería la matriz
12 36
aumentada con la columna ahora 1 2
bien así que tengo que llevar estas
matrices a su forma escalonada reducida
por renglones así que vamos a hacerlas
simultáneamente vamos a hacerlas
simultáneamente y que nos da pues si le
cambio vamos a
vamos a dejar el primer renglón como
esta 130 y voy a cambiar el segundo
renglón por el segundo renglón menos dos
veces el primer renglón y eso que me da
sería 2 - 2 x 1 que sería 2 - 2 sería
cero y luego seis menos dos por 36 menos
6 que es otro 00 menos dos veces cero es
cero
y aquí hacemos exactamente lo mismo
afortunadamente solo me interesa el lado
izquierdo realmente ok entonces el
primer renglón se queda igual 1 3 1
y el segundo renglón se convierte en el
segundo menos dos veces el primero dos
menos dos veces uno es 06 - dos veces
tres es cero y dos menos dos veces uno
es cero y ya acabamos aquí tenemos ya la
solución a nuestro sistema ahora sí se
dan cuenta esta columna aquí la primera
columna es una columna pivote y
corresponde a x1 así que eso me dice que
x1 es una variable pivote también si se
dan cuenta
esta segunda columna esta segunda
columna esta no es una columna pivote no
tiene ningún uno así que está que
corresponde a la variable x2 debe ser
una variable libre esta columna también
así que no lo noto x2
una variable variable libre
libre perfecto ok entonces yo le puedo
dar cualquier valor a x2 así que vamos a
decir que x2 es igual a te conté un
número real
bien y si hago esto si hago esto cuánto
vale x 1 pues no tengo que esta primera
esta primera este primer renglón me dice
que x 1 + 3 veces x 2 es igual a 0
y entonces esto es lo mismo que si le
restó tres veces x2 de ambos lados esto
se convierte en x1 es igual a menos 3
veces x 2 pero si x2 vale t esto es lo
mismo que x1 es igual a menos 3 veces
y que hay de este lado pues aquí tengo
que x 1 + 3 veces x 2 es igual a 1
así que restando 3 veces x 2 de ambos
lados tengo que x 1 es igual a 1 menos 3
veces x 2 de nuevo x 2 ballet es así que
x 1 es igual a 1 - 3 t y esto esto ya me
permite escribir los conjuntos solución
de un buen modo vamos a primero escribir
las soluciones a esta en esta ecuación
las voy a escribir como sigue las
soluciones a esta ecuación son a la
primera actuación los vectores x 1 x 2
que tienen la forma
que tienen la forma que es un parámetro
libre te pertenece a los reales así que
déjenlo factor hizo de gemelo factor
hizo y entonces x2 es igual a t así que
este por 1
por el otro lado x 1 para la primera
ecuación vale menos tres veces t así que
aquí sería menos 3
esas son las soluciones a esta primera
ecuación conté en los reales y que desde
la segunda ecuación
qué hay de esta ecuación de aquí
pues son los vectores
x 1 x 2
tales que son de la forma este es un
poco más engañoso de nuevo voy a
factorizar aquí la t
x2 de nuevo aquí sería por uno que esté
esta es la convención que hicimos acá
arriba
x 1 vale 13 t así que lo que voy a hacer
es tomar aquí este menos 3
pero me falta este uno así que voy a
pensar en el vector 10
más tevez es el vector menos 31 donde el
nuevo t está en los reales y en un
segundo voy a graficar esto para que
veamos cómo se ve muy bien así que la
prima gen del conjunto es la pre imagen
de ese que eran estos dos vectores y
aquí está formada precisamente por los
vectores de esta forma y los vectores de
esta forma así que vamos a graficar eso
para tener una mejor idea que está
sucediendo déjenme activo una gráfica ya
que estoy aquí también voy a copiar este
resultado no es llevar abajo
muy bien baja buenos amigos damos aquí
está bien
vamos a ponerlo por acá
y vamos a activar mi gráfica perfecto
entonces si gráfico el vector menos 31
estaría graficando un vector que apunta
a este punto aquí y se vería algo así
ese es el vector menos 3 1 y entonces
este conjunto azul este conjunto de aquí
sería esta línea recta porque son todos
los múltiplos escalares de ese vector
naranja así que es una línea que tiene
precisamente la dirección del vector
naranja y del mismo modo si quisiera
graficar este vector digo perdón este
conjunto entonces primero me mueva el
punto 1010 que es ese punto de allí y
después de nuevo son múltiplos escalares
de este vector naranja así que este
conjunto rosado sería este aquí sería
una línea paralela una línea paralela a
la línea azul
desplazada un poco hacia la derecha
perfecto y recuerden que todo esto todo
esto surgió de querer encontrar la pre
imagen de ese respecto a ti es decir de
querer encontrar los puntos en r2 que se
transformaban ya sea el vector 0 0 que
sería el conjunto azul o al vector 12
que sería el conjunto rosado así que
podemos aquí hacer lo siguiente aquí
tengo el vector 0 0 es ese punto de ahí
y el vector 12 es este punto acá
entonces todos los vectores que apunten
a punto sobre la línea azul todos los
vectores en la línea azul se transforman
en el vector 0 0 todos los estos van a
dar al vector 0 0 bajo la transformación
y todos todos los vectores sobre la
línea rosada van a dar
al vector 12 bajo la transformación t
así que eso significa la pre imagen son
los vectores que van a dar a este punto
al 0 0 o a este punto al 12 y de hecho
estos vectores que están sobre la línea
azul los que pertenecen a este conjunto
que vamos a llamar l él le va a hacer
esta línea azul celeste que está aquí
tienen una propiedad muy especial porque
esos son los vectores x tales que su
transformación nos da el vector 0 es
decir todos los que están sobre la línea
azul todos los que están sobre esta
línea se transforman en el vector 0 en
el 0 0 y de hecho esto ya más o menos lo
habíamos mencionado cuando dije que esto
de aquí era precisamente el espacio nulo
de esta matriz ahora en este caso
multiplicar por esta matriz equivale a
realizar nuestra transformación t así
que lo que estoy diciendo son todos los
vectores que se transforman en el vector
0 y esto es un conjunto muy muy
importante es tan importante que tiene
su propio nombre
a los vectores que cumplen esta
condición que su transformación sea
igual a cero se les llama el núcleo el
núcleo
núcleo de la transformación de el núcleo
de t
y a veces también le llaman el vino
digamos esto es lo mismo que el kernel y
kernel de la transformación t en cuanto
a la anotación algunas personas usan
nunca
dt que sería la más común porque viene
el núcleo y a veces verán escrito kernel
que el dt pero bueno lo que es es
sencillamente el conjunto de puntos los
x en el dominio de la transformación los
x en el dominio de t
tales que te aplicada a el vector x nos
da el vector 0 eso es el núcleo en este
caso como es en r2 son los x n r 2 que
al aplicarles la transformación nos dan
el vector 0 y como vimos si puede
representar una transformación lineal
por una matriz que de hecho eso siempre
se puede si la transformación aplicada x
es lo mismo que una matriz a por el
vector x entonces el núcleo de t
es igual a el espacio nulo de la matriz
a y bueno espero que esto les haya
resultado al menos un poco interesante